Lizzie avec Maya à 9h
[Musique]
désolé pour ton match mais on va
s'éclater ce soir
laisse-moi deviner encore un congrès
d'informatique
il y a une urgence au boulot de papa tu
peux me récupérer je kiffe trop quand tu
m'appelles maman maintenant on se met un
gros tarif
pas quoi là
je t'en supplie touche pas
[Musique]
trop la classe
tu es un genre de repère pour
super-héros ça veut dire que c'est lui
le garde
mon père s'est trompé
je viens d'avoir une idée assez dingue
ça c'est de la vitesse
on tient
celui qui a cette technologie peut tout
faire
on doit sauver l'arbre secret de mon
père avant qu'il détruise le monde
on va réussir
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire avec ça me
chatouiller à mort
t'es fou c'était trop long c'était
beaucoup trop long c'est bon je ne suis
que l'informaticien j'ai eu un signal
d'alerte il y aurait une fac de sécurité
pourquoi tu m'as caché ton identité
secrète comment je dois dire ça pendant
que j'y pense une puissance venue
d'ailleurs m'a choisi moi comme ange
gardien de la planète je passerai pour
un cinglé oui
fin de la récré les gars
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]